new york state assembly speaker says he
will make no deals with governor andrew
cuomo who faces possible impeachment
after accusations of sexual harassment
pressure on the governor to resign has
increased after one of his 11
public accusers spoke with us and
albany's times union newspaper
in an exclusive interview brittany
camiso says cuomo groped her at the
governor's mansion last year
our national correspondent jerica duncan
has covered this story for months and
she's with us now erica good morning
how soon could the governor be impeached
well the chairman of the state
assembly's judiciary committee says
there could be a vote on articles of
impeachment within
several weeks it's a long process here
the committee is reviewing evidence and
interviews from the attorney general's
investigation before lawmakers decide
if they will draw up articles of
impeachment against the governor
the governor has clearly lost the
confidence of the majority members of
the new york state assembly
the new york assembly's judiciary
committee met monday to discuss
potential articles of impeachment for
sexual misconduct against governor
andrew cuomo
also being considered whether the
governor lied about the number of
coveted related nursing home deaths
his possible use of state resources for
a more than 5
million dollar book deal and whether the
governor prioritized kovat testing for
family and friends
at the beginning of the pandemic we
anticipate
that this process will be concluded
very soon next and when i say very soon
i'm speaking about
several weeks assembly majority leader
crystal people stokes is one of the many
state democratic lawmakers who have
called on the governor to resign
although she says he deserves due
process it's got to be done correctly
and it's got to be done right
their inquiry comes as an explosive
report from the state's attorney general
concluded the governor sexually harassed
multiple women
and violated federal and state laws in
an exclusive interview with cbs
and albany's times union brittany
comisso identified in the report as
executive assistant number one revealed
she has already been interviewed by
assembly impeachment investigators
what would be the appropriate punishment
do you think for the governor is it
enough
if he were to just resign
i do think he needs to resign and i also
do think that he needs to
see counseling i do think that he needs
professional help i do think that he
you know he has many things that he
needs to work through
governor cuomo has denied all wrongdoing
and has remained largely out of sight
cuomo's most trusted aide melissa derosa
resigned sunday and in a letter to
colleagues she said
she's forever grateful to the governor
the governor has until friday to submit
evidence in his defense to the judiciary
committee even if the governor
does resign he could still be impeached
and if convicted could be barred from
ever holding state office
again tony all right thank you very much
for